hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I O
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught Philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on One Core concept from
an important philosophical text I hope
you find it useful as well
in book one of his work on anger one of
the arguments that Seneca is going to
take on directly appears to be coming
from the aristotelians but there's
plenty of other people who are probably
making this in ancient times as well and
the idea is that anger although not
something necessarily good or natural
does provide us with Resources with
energy that we need and so it can be
looked at as a useful thing right as
perhaps an ally
to reason or to Virtue so that Without
Anger you can't really accomplish what
you need to and there are a number of
arguments that he's going to very
briefly present that we could unpack a
little bit for anger as a useful Ally or
adjunct something that's helpful
atsumenda right in this case
so the first one that he considers is
that it raises our spirits and Spurs us
on right so it it helps to get us riled
up it helps to motivate us that's uh an
important function of anger for many
people you can go to the gym and you get
angry at the weights or at the track or
at whatever and then you've got that
extra burst of energy to get something
accomplished right or somebody tells you
oh you're no good and you're like well
I'll show them you know and then you
rise to the occasion okay so so that's
one way that people do in fact
understand and depict anger I mean we
see this in a lot of TV shows and movies
and stuff like that
then he goes on a little bit further and
he's going to tie it in with the virtue
of Courage so he says that without it
courage accomplishes nothing Splendid in
Warfare it needs that flame set to the
kindling that goad to stir the bold and
get them to to do you know what they
need to do to send them into Harm's Way
now this is a little bit of a funny way
to construe things right because if you
have the virtue of Courage won't you
already be doing those sorts of things
well
um some people I guess in ancient times
and I think there's plenty of people in
in the present often confuse anger and
courage Aristotle even talks about this
in Nika McCann ethics book three that
thumos uh is not really courage although
people can be motivated by that oh as
can animals as well here the argument is
that Courage by itself isn't going to be
entirely effective without the addition
the help of anger and he says that's the
reason some people think it's best to
control anger to temperate it right to
bring it within certain bounds this is
completely Aristotle's position when it
comes to the virtue of what he calls
mildness proud taste or good temper and
now this is not actually Aristotle's
position that we need anger in order to
do courageous things but perhaps there's
Italians out there or perhaps this is an
Aristotelian text that Seneca has access
to that we no longer have and so he says
it's best to control anger not to do
away with it who wants to do away with
it the stoics Seneca right actually some
other people as well like Cicero and he
says we can reduce it to what he calls a
healthy mean salutaram modem okay well
this is very explicitly an Aristotelian
idea there the mean as The Virtuous
position the the good position we strip
away the excess retain the element that
prevents action from turning feeble and
the mind's Vivid energy from being
sapped Okay so we've got a position here
that's pretty clear
anger can in fact be useful as a matter
of fact you might even not just find it
useful but even necessary if you want to
do the sorts of things that courage
requires stoics just like aristotelians
think that courage is one of the most
important of the virtues the stoics
actually make it a cardinal or primary
virtue
now Seneca says this is not a good line
of reasoning why not and he he's going
to give you several different
considerations
the first is as he says it's easier to
keep harmful agents out than to control
them once you let them in so the idea is
that the stems from the stoic uh
anthropology or understanding of human
nature there is there isn't a rational
part that's totally separate from the
passions or emotions as there is in
platonism or aristotelianism for the
stoics or the rational part is also the
part in which we feel the Passions
so you start letting them in and they're
going to screw things up
once you start admitting anger as a
helper it's actually going to start
taking over like you know some friend
who always makes everything about them
all right you could say so he says don't
admit them because then it's much more
difficult to direct and control them
once they've been admitted once they've
taken up tenancy they're more powerful
than the one who would rule them and
they tolerate No cutbacks or didn't
ignition so what this is saying is you
can't really control anger once you let
it in there there isn't a Aristotelian
proper mean for anger let that passion
in and everything goes goes haywire and
you're probably actually going to think
that you are controlling it when you're
not controlling because anger is going
to lie to you as well so that's the
first thing that he says the second
which is very similar to it he says in
the second place reason itself which is
entrusted with the Reigns right Reigns
are how you guide a horse and so you
know reason is supposed to be riding the
horse the horse could be anything you
like the passions reason should be in
charge it's in control only so long as
it's kept as he says separate from the
passions so once again don't let the
passions in once it has mingled with
them and become polluted it cannot keep
them in check though it could have kept
them out thought once it has been shaken
and dislodged from its proper footing
becomes the slave of the thing that
pushes it along so if you're going to
let anger in Anger is going to run the
show reason is going to be doing anger's
bidding not the other way around these
are very similar points that he's making
and he goes on with this and he's got a
nice image once so he says certain
things are within our control at first
whereas the subsequent stages carry us
along with a force all of their own and
leave us no way back so once you do
certain things that were in your control
it's no longer in your control he tells
us that here's a great example people
who have jumped off a cliff rotate no
independent judgment can offer cannot
offer resistance or slow The Descent of
their bodies in free fall that
irrevocable leap strips away all the
Liberation and regret you jump off the
cliff you're going down right
you I mean if you don't have like an
antidote you inject yourself with a
poison
ah you're gonna die you you've chosen it
you could be like oops I shouldn't have
done that but now it's too late right so
anger he's saying is like that just as
much as is love
and other passions so he says Once the
mind has
submit it right once it is given into a
passion
the mind is essentially taken over by
that passion and that passion is running
the show it's not allowed as he says to
check it's onrush its own weight and the
downward tending nature of vices must
carry it along and drive it down Into
the Depths and the stoics do think of
the uh various passions not all emotions
but many of the emotions as being
vicious so they're going to drag you
down now he's got some other
considerations just a little bit later
in the text he says that anger doesn't
actually have anything useful about it
and it doesn't actually stir the mind to
war-like Deeds the way that people who
are claiming we need it pretend that it
does now the argument that he's going to
get here doesn't really combat that
second part anger could in fact stir the
mind to warlike Deeds it's just not
doing it in a good way as he'll say
later Iran but there is a very important
consideration here
he tells us that virtue shouldn't be
assisted by Vice it doesn't make sense
for virtue to be helped out by Vice any
more than it would and this is not his
analogy but just my own as it would to
protect your house you need to bring in
a robber you know somebody oh a thief is
a good person to set up your security
system no they're not
they're going to come in and Rob you
because they know the codes to your
security system you know this is a
terrible logic you don't need Vice to
help out virtue why because virtue is
sufficient in itself you could you could
go on a little bit further and say if
you think you have virtue but you need
Vice to support it you don't actually
have any virtue you're mistaken about
that and he goes on and he says where
there's need of aggressive action virtue
doesn't grow angry
but virtue stirs you up if you have a
properly functioning practical reason if
you have developed virtue namely that of
Courage you will not need anger in order
to stir you to do the right thing to
take on dangers to take aggressive
action if needed and like he says it
stirred only so much as it reckons
necessary and then it grows calm just as
missiles let fly by catapults are in the
control of the artillery man who
calibrate the catapult's torque once you
shoot the missile you don't need to be
like you know getting ready to shoot the
same thing again you've already you just
let it go you've done the action
now you can be called
you know if you shouted at somebody you
don't need to keep on shouting at them
and he he uh goes on and he tells us
that Aristotle says anger is necessary
nor can any struggle be carried to
Victory without it
um it must be employed as a foot soldier
not the general and then Seneca says
well that's actually wrong here's why if
it listens to reason and follow where
reason leads it's no longer anger which
has Defiance as its defining trait but
if it fights against reason it is still
not it is not still when ordered and is
carried forward by ferocious desire it
says useless as the Mind servant as a
soldier who ignores the signal for a
retreat you want reason to be running
the show if anger does in fact listen to
reasons no longer anger it's something
else that we're dealing with because
anger in its very nature is not subject
to reason it will take over instead and
he's got this great line he says that
the path passions are just as bad
as soldiers than they as they are as
generals why because a useful Soldier
will know how to act in accordance with
the strategy where does the strategy
come from it doesn't come from anger I
mean bad strategies could come from
anger go storm that Hill you know don't
worry about the machine guns not a good
strategy right let's wait until we do
the artillery bombardment and then we'll
go storm the hill that's a little bit
more reasonable you know so we'll sit
around and wait even though you want to
go attack right away your buddy just got
shot you want to Revenge them let's wait
for the artillery to happen and then
we'll go Brave this this danger so
Seneca is saying this metaphor of
soldiers and Generals I mean if you
really apply it anger is a bad General
it's also a bad Soldier it doesn't obey
the orders that it should be
and he goes on a little bit further and
he's got a conclusion here reason will
never add
imprudent right improvidos so not
thinking things through and violent
violetes uh impulses impetus to its
Armory or to its its resources you could
say over these reason has no Authority
could never restrain them without
setting similar counter impulses against
them and he he gives an example about
how we could take the passions and try
to orient them against each other so
fear against anger he says anger against
sluggishness desire against fear
but if we do that we're really just sort
of like coordinating the passions and
this is not very helpful at all we you
know it's sort of like saying well you
know the ship is leaning over this way
let's set some depth charges to knock it
back this way no let's let's just like
actually calibrate things properly maybe
move some of the cargo and now the ship
steers itself properly so reason really
shouldn't rely on anger nor should
virtue as an ally as a resource as a
even a foot soldier if we want to use
that metaphor according to Seneca
because when you do that you're
inevitably going to screw things up
within yourself whatever virtue you have
is going to be you know lost
rationality reason is not going to be
properly functioning so we don't want to
rely on anger as an ally AI